molto moltissimo ma vaffan
fu così è stata rapita nel secolo
malizia quella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
che sono mi è arrivato un messaggio
messaggio e non urlare a quella tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
sono fa vj ed oggi siamo addio ma non
acceso le luci che bordello mi metto un
cazzo giochiamo a slitta io quando non
si vede un cazzo perfetto non mi sono
scusate sono stupido non acceso le luci
siamo tornati su slitte rio il problema
è bastata skin che palle sempre questa è
l michia la gara non avevo visto da roma
delle schermate fermi un attimo devo
apprezzare la bellezza delle nuove skin
è ancora quello di pd paino cazzo
antonia raco l'ho trovato io dico io più
di pino padre pio padre prima che i
ragazzi siamo cosa sta succedendo raga
ok si è che cazzo successo no ma se non
ho capito o pacato sluyter io perché sto
cambiando skin ogni tre secondi no vabbè
ho pagato sluyter io non ci credo mai se
non so che ho fatto è un bug per forza
perché non ho mai visto nessuno così
cioè guardatevi in giro meno mai visto
nessuno che lampeggia e che cambia skin
ogni tre secondi come ho fatto a pagarlo
sedile ok obiettivo diventare primi così
che c'è la gente mi guarda come dire ma
che cazzo è sta roba poi diventò anche
primo cioè la potenza di chi cambia skin
non sarà un superpotere che mi servirà a
vincere però almeno sono figo non
avverrà chiama quanto efficacia cosa
guarda che roba è la cosa più bella che
abbia mai visto o ragazze ho la licenza
per vincere devo arrivare assolutamente
primo o un tentativo perché sicuramente
se muoio non mi ricapita di essere
pagato così quindi non devo morire mai
praticamente la prima primo tentativo
devo vincere ce la mettono tutta la cava
lo prometto alla carica
e vai vai vai vai che sta già diventando
grosso come morto questo ma da quanto
sono grosso e mentre cambia anche skin
ed è bellissimo sera vabbè lega che che
effetto strano che fa se fossi morto
subito sarebbe stato un peccato perché
non avrei sfruttato al meglio ma almeno
sono inventato già grosso allora com'è
che la gente che tenta di uccidermi
perché mi vede lampeggiare no no no no
l'ho perso lo credimi che c'è ancora ti
prego perché è rimasto tech è perfetto
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai stavolta già
faccio a ecco perché il server è lo
stesso per quello sarà rimasto è
impossibile se non la capisco se cambio
server sicuramente cambia sta cosa la
madre va bene calmi tutti vi prego
quanto casinò c'è qua ma [ __ ] ai legami
che lasciava mi porterà sfiga sta cosa
che cambia skin ogni tre secondi per
forza perché inga non ci posso credere
che gli ultimi due episodi o fatti cui a
strisce questo qua non riesco a far
niente non so perché regala credo che
sta skin non mi porti poi così bene però
è bella a vedersi l'importante è quello
ma tu breve va bene ma nova tv di tutti
i miei tutti i miei sentimenti mi hanno
tutti i miei perfetto è riuscito a
rinchiudere un sacco di punti sono tutti
i miei questi regata aac grandissimo
casi o non ti spaventare se cambiano i
tre secondi io sono più bello che culo
che culo che va bene l'ho ucciso sono
forte sono figo ok più di fi certo ci
credo che sei tu zio ci credo se sei pd
pie sono è più forte ma che fosse stato
lui la skin più bella cielo qua io sono
il più figo di tutto sleeper io io ti
globo come tua madre se non ti in globo
butti prenderò a sediate e non ce l'ho
fatta ragazza non ce l'ho fatta pro
forse questo sì forse questo figli
non ce la faccio [ __ ] non si fa a
inglobare nessuno oggi questa storia
solo perché lampeggio questo razzismo
nei confronti chi cambia la skin ogni 13
secondi è risaputo ragazzi che i
serpenti cambiano pelle però non pensavo
così ma che poi slip ma così possono
esser picchio sono vermi sono sempre
verni sempreverdi l'iter mi fa slither
sarebbe serpe niente sono serpenti
sempre creduto fossero vermi devi
inchinarti al mio cospetto se non ti
inclini io nel ca pranzi te lo metto e
te pareva devi crepare è fatta ce l'ho
fatta sono fatta s'è inchinato ragazzo
noi più grande era un pò i [ __ ]
e c'è un motivo se mi chiamò berlusconi
che immette trovo così senza un cazzo di
motivo comunque canticchio così l'ho
preso da amedeo preziosi che so decimi
su decimi
stiamo per dirvi ragazzi una roba che
mentre guardavo la mia posizione in
classifica per caso visto il punteggio
del primo in classifica
nego ioni 68 mila punti ditemi voi se
devo entrare sempre mi server dove porca
pupazza c'è sempre qualcuno che fa i
punti infiniti ma come fa a sta gente mi
chiama quanto sta fermi periferici
arrivo seriosi no perchè me li devono
inglobare tutti che morisse il gatto
camia presso la più grosso qui e posso
anche pensarlo inglobarli tipo così tipo
così
mi puoi morire per cortesia mi fai
spiace grazie ha fatto davvero e molto
sul serio
no è sparito il bagno è sparito il bug
[ __ ] ancora non me n'ero accorto
ragazzi o lampeggiato per un periodo che
è stato il periodo più bello della mia
vita però purtroppo non possiamo
lampeggiare in e terra perché anche noi
verbi dobbiamo morire sap enti scusate
sapete questo è chiamato al red
lamborghini va bene ti chiami il red
lamborghini almeno fatti di colore rosso
frate almeno quello ma tu sono passato
tipo uno spazio né inesistente ragazzi
non so come ho fatto dai ammazziamo
qualcuno mi sto rompendo bene forza la
borghini e crepa che due palle niente
non credo a nessuno gira bene finché non
diventerò un nano minuscole non c'è
verso non ci posso fare altro che vi
fate provare a gariglio a gariglio fammi
vedere che è cagata è non mai provato è
come funziona deve inglobare questi è
cosa devo fare
a quelli più grossi inglobano con i più
piccoli che bello ma non puoi non puoi
neanche tipo accerchiare la gente va miu
miu e di qua qualcuno si faccia uccidere
ecco lo ha ucciso a testa di cazzo ma
apre su facebook li sapremo barra
spaziatrice mi divido a che cosa minchia
serve a cosa dovrebbe servire dividersi
non ho capito
e ciò che va bene ragazzi proviamo
l'ultima litterio ringraziando iddio
proviamo l'ultima volta l'ultimo
tentativo giusto per 11 a 2 e romano e
sono uscito ci sono riuscito ucciderne
due così va bene ora che mi fotte i
punti sto deficienti li ho fatti fuori
io mica dedicarsi vogliono ha ucciso io
ma cosa vuoi da ucciso lui questo non
glielo vado a prendere volevo però non
sono andato perché sono una brava
persona invece no
quando li ammazzo io dovete rubarmi
punti brutti deficienti come se non
ragazzi non ce la posso più fare ve lo
giuro boicotterò solite rio dei salati
non faccio più episodi di tehreek e un
pochino barbie fatemi giocare un minuto
e vabbè dai ma quanto culo puoi avere
ragazzi non c'è verso oggi non c'è billy
ballo è quando billy ballo arriva sesto
e tu non riesce a fare due punti in
croce c'è qualche problema è tech
vabbè è morto è morto e molte morte
morte morte ma tutto dei fatti i cazzi
tuoi che edito nell'anno grandissimo
tutti morti
vai vai forza che si possono tanti
tradizione stavo per uccidere pure lui
dai sarebbe stata la causa del secolo ma
litio